aquí tenemos una suma de riman con el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito y el
objetivo de este vídeo es ver si podemos
reescribir esto como una integral
definida los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y tratan de resolver esto por su
cuenta
recordemos como una integral definida se
relaciona con una suma de riman tengo la
integral definida de a a b de fx de x y
como ya hemos visto en otros vídeos esto
es igual al límite cuando n tiende a
infinito de la suma con sigma mayúscula
que va desde igual a uno hasta n
esencialmente vamos a sumar las áreas de
muchos rectángulos donde la base de
estos rectángulos que escribimos como
delta x y la altura será el valor de la
función f x evaluada en algún lugar de
esa delta x cuando hacemos una suma de
riman por la derecha el valor que
usaremos aquí será la altura del lado
derecho de este rectángulo así que
comenzamos en el límite inferior a y
sumamos tantas delta x como especifica
nuestro índice
y es igual a 1 entonces sumamos una
delta x estaremos en el lado derecho del
primer rectángulo si y es igual a 2
entonces sumaremos 2 delta x y así
sucesivamente lo de aquí queda como
delta x por el índice y esta es la forma
general que habíamos con anterioridad
una posibilidad es intentar reconocer un
patrón aquí nuestra función luce como la
función logaritmo natural esto sería
nuestra fx lo escribimos fx es igual a
logaritmo natural de x que más
encontramos a luce como 2 y cuál será
nuestra delta x vemos esto que está
multiplicando y que está dividido entre
n y que no está siendo x y luce como
nuestra delta x y esto de aquí luce como
delta x x y así que nuestra delta x es
igual a 5 / n podemos decir que esto es
igual a la integral definida de
conocemos el límite de integración
inferior que es 2 pero aún no conocemos
el límite de integración superior de
nuestra función es el logaritmo natural
de x
y aquí al final escribimos de equis para
terminar de escribir esta integral
definida
necesitamos encontrar el límite superior
y la forma de encontrar el límite
superior es analizando nuestra delta x
la forma en la que definimos esta delta
x en esta suma de ruymán es la
diferencia entre nuestros límites de
integración dividida entre las secciones
que queremos tener que es n así que esto
es igual a b menos a entre n aquí
reemplazamos lo que conocemos
esto es delta x así que aquí escribimos
b menos a que sabemos es 2 entre n b
menos dos es igual a 5 por lo que ve es
7 ahora si ya encontramos el límite
superior de la integral que es 7 y ya
tenemos nuestra suma de riman reescrita
como una integral definida nuevamente
quiero hacer énfasis en porque esto
tiene sentido si gráfica mos esto
luciría así vamos a hacerlo a mano
esto de aquí es uno y vamos de 2 a 7
aunque no es algo exacto la integral
definida es el área bajo la curva entre
2 y 7 podemos ver la suma de riman como
una aproximación cuando n no tiende a
infinito pero cuando decimos y es igual
a 1 el primer rectángulo tendrá una base
de 5 entre n
así que decimos que la diferencia entre
2 y 7 esta distancia de 5 la dividimos
entre n rectángulos el primer rectángulo
tiene una base de 5 entre m y cuál será
la altura como es una suma de riman por
la derecha usaremos el valor de la
función justo aquí en 25 entre n este
valor de aquí es el logaritmo natural de
25 entre m y como es nuestro primer
rectángulo lo multiplicamos por 1
continuamos haciendo esto el segundo
rectángulo tiene una base igual de 5
entre n pero la altura será el logaritmo
natural de 2 + 5 / n x 2
esto es para cuando y es igual a 2 el
anterior es para cuando y es igual a 1
espero que con esto ustedes vean que
tiene sentido el área del primer
rectángulo es el logaritmo natural de 2
+ 5 / n x 1 x 5 / m el área del segundo
rectángulo es el logaritmo natural de
dos más 5 x 2 / n x 5 / m y todo esto
está calculando la suma del área de
todos estos rectángulos pero está
tomando el límite cuando n se aproxima a
infinito por lo que tendremos una mejor
aproximación cada vez para calcular el
área exacta